[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
louis riddick will be on the main set
for the nfl draft on espn once again
mike greenberg and booger mcfarland uh
they'll be uh
from cleveland espn and abc will both
televise the draft
all three days april 29th through may
1st as we bring in the uh
former defensive back and uh former nfl
pro scout director of pro personnel
louis
let me uh hit you with the poll question
let's take out trevor lawrence the guy
that you
say can't miss in the first 10 picks is
who i'm going to say it's jamar
chase i just think look you got to
remember back in 2019 when this young
man was 19 years old
he put together one of the greatest
seasons you'll ever see a wide receiver
put together
and it wasn't simply because
lsu was better than everyone else it
wasn't simply because joe burrow wound
up being the number one overall pick
it was because this guy torched every
single
sec defensive back he went up against
and many of them were very good
very good players who wanted getting
drafted high in the nfl
and when you just think when you look at
how
just how he's constructed as far as his
body type i mean the guy is rock solid i
mean he's a monster and he's fast
and he doesn't drop passes he runs great
routes he can run inside he can run
outside he can run
deep he can run short he can run after
the catch he can beat you in 50 50 balls
i don't know what else really you want
him to do and
he's just hyper competitive so i mean i
think whoever takes him
is instantly getting to 1200 1300 yard
receiver
where do you stand on the best tight end
in the league uh
going into the draft of the best
offensive linemen if i said you could
have kyle pitts or
penny sewell and both both are going to
work out but
the priority of getting a great tight
end or a great offensive lineman
well i think in the in the context of
team building dan
i'm always going to go inside out i'm
always going to build the team front to
back so i'm going gonna make sure i take
care of the people who are throwing the
football to those guys who are pretty
catching the ball on the outside
and that's why i wouldn't when the
conversation comes up about cincinnati
or
well i'm really not about atlanta
because the land is not in the market
for a tackle but when the conversation
comes up for cincinnati
that's why i'm always going to defer to
either
pine soul or rashaan slater in order to
protect joe burrow you you just can't
you can't get by without it and i think
in a in a
small way although it was a big game on
a great stage
we learned that in the super bowl this
past year yeah i just brought that up
i agree with you to ignore that you're
just kind of like defying what the
football gods have always told you
is you better take care of your lines i
know it doesn't sound
it's not fun because you know kyle pitts
is probably going to
do some damage on somebody's fantasy
team next year but that's not the point
these two young tackles sewell and
slater
and or guards whatever wherever you want
to play them are going to be pro bowlers
and probably going to be all pros very
quickly
you have atlantic four and there's sort
of the mystery team here
if somebody get a trade out are they
going to take a quarterback
are you going to take kyle picks let's
say you're running the falcons
yeah knowing what you know right now
draft is tonight
and you know who's going one two well
you sort of know who's going one two and
three
do you think mack jones is going three
i do until until you know the
the data or rather the information
that's coming in says otherwise and look
the information that we're getting
we're primarily getting from people who
are dialed in and tapped into the people
who are making those decisions
in a way that we know history has proven
that these guys are rarely wrong all
right
so it can it makes sense to me as to why
they would go mac jones because and i've
talked about this a lot about
quarterback play is just not about
physical traits when we get on shows
like this dan we've been we've talked
and you've talked to many people about
this what happens usually
what is the reason why people usually
bust out of the league especially a
quarterback
it's not because well that guy just
didn't have enough arm strength that guy
just couldn't create enough plays off
that's not why it's because something
happened
upstairs in his mind whether it be the
way he played the game on the field
from an intelligent perspective or the
way he took care of himself off the
field
that's usually what happens it's
something as far as the way they're
wired
no one has any issues as a matter of
fact everyone is louding matt jones for
the way he's wired
some great quarterback coaches and
offensive coordinators are
are praising them for that and kyle and
and whoever else is advising him whether
it be his father mike or whoever
they know this too so it wouldn't shock
me if they take him now at the same time
you know you hear i heard people over
the weekend talking about the fact that
trey lance could sway them today with
his pro day
trey lance swayed me from the very first
time i talked to him and then i watched
him on his first pro day
don't discount him i understand his
resume isn't as long look i think
everything is up
is on the table for them i really do but
when people as connected as adam
schefter say what they say
and then he continues to say until
proven until i
hear information otherwise this is where
i'm going with it then i'm going with it
okay so if you're atlanta you're running
atlanta you're on the clock
let's say mac jones has just been
selected and
the atlanta falcons select
you know actually what i'm trying to do
is i'm trying to trade down that's what
i'm starting to do
okay you can't trade down i know so
now you're saying do i pick a player
right
all right look i'm one of those people
who likes to think about the long term
really okay
let me just tell you what my thought
process is first of all the very first
thing i need
in atlanta is defense but i'm going i
can't get great i can't get value at
four
i can't that's why i said i want to
trade down second okay now what do i
want do i want to think about the long
term as far as making sure i have an
heir apparent to matt ryan
or do i need something right now in the
short term to appease my head coach
who says matt ryan can play for three or
four more years
and maybe address my quarterback
position somewhere down the line
you're running out of time with your
draft you know what i'm probably going
to turn in the card for kyle pitts
that's what i'm going to do i agree with
you atlanta's problems are defensively
in my yeah so but you can't i don't know
of
who's going to trade up and then what do
you get when you trade back down there
yeah you don't want to go too far if
you're atlanta you don't want to get out
of the mix you don't want to get out of
the
you know maybe somebody wants to come up
there and somebody wants to
grab either tray lance or justin fields
or whoever it is at that point in time
that's what you're that's what you're
banking on
you know we've heard that we've heard
that denver could possibly be a mover
although there are people who said they
have not called atlanta to move up the
floor yet
that's what i'm hoping though i'll tell
you this i'm gonna wait until the very
last second to turn in that card
that's what i'm doing he's uh louis
riddick from the mothership
anything in the profile in sports
illustrated on trevor lawrence
concern you you know there was a lot of
bruja over what i said
uh late last week about this it caught
my attention then
all right it caught my attention because
when we're talking about quarterbacks
when we're talking about quarterbacks
we're going to be drafted number one
overall i know
trevor said he loves the game and he
wants to be the best ever to play it
i know okay and i know he says he
doesn't have a chip on his shoulder
that's great i never said anything about
that but i will say this quarterbacks in
the nfl coaches in the nfl will tell you
the game is much
harder at the nfl level and requires a
different level of preparation and a
different mindset than whatever you had
when you thought when you were in
college
it's that and we know this and i know
this as a player
it's totally different so it made me
think okay
well i know he's gotten by with
everything that he's done the way he's
done it so far he's been the best on the
field every time he stepped on the field
except for maybe when they played ohio
state and justin feels the best the
field
but you know i i disinterested to see
what his approach is and how he talks
about the game
once he gets the jacksonville and things
aren't as easy for him as they were at
clemson
that's kind of i'm interested to hear
hear how he talks about the game then
and as far as his preparation and what
his mindset is or doesn't it change
or does he remain the same person and
just say say hey look i'm still not
driven by super bowls
i'm not driven by accolades that's just
not who i am
does he remain that guy and if he does
great but the expectations are much
different are going to be much different
for him in jacksonville than they ever
were at even clemson
because he's the number one pick in the
draft and the last thing i said about
that was this
if other players in the nfl whether it
be quarterback or otherwise
had even intimated in any way that
football wasn't the number one thing
that they
that that on their priority list and
they weren't driven maniacally to be the
best they could possibly be
we would have discussions about it but
for trevor all of a sudden it's like
it's not allowed you can't you can't say
anything about him
look at what he's done and it wasn't me
i wasn't trying to disparage the guy and
i wasn't trying to criticize him
i was just raising the question of okay
well how would we react to other people
had they said this kind of thing
or people around them who know them very
well had said this kind of thing
but this is the game is different this
is the first time he's been critiqued
nationally um on the field or off the
field
but you it's not a coincidence though
lewis that you look at some of the great
quarterbacks of all time
and they have a chip on their shoulder
montana taken in the third round
mourinho went all the way at the end of
the first round aaron rodgers all the
way at the first round mahomes got
passed up drew brees got passed to
go down the list i mean peyton payton
was not like you know he was taking
number one overall
right unless he says well i should have
won the heisman like
you create a chip if you don't have a
chip lord knows brady certainly is
still working on that chip sure but i i
don't think it's a coincidence
that these guys who have been successful
um you know had a chip on their shoulder
sure
look i i think again you know it's
interesting
it's interesting that you know we you
know a lot of the conversations
surrounding the draft is about kyle
shanahan in san francisco
the guy who articulated it in the in the
most
real way from a coaching perspective to
me about what they thought
really built the kind of culture that's
a winning sustainable culture in the nfl
was kyle shanahan and he said this
you know we were talking until monday
night football production meetings he
said
once you get enough guys who realize
how hard this game is and really kind of
intrinsically
the number one thing that they need is
this
game this game is everything to them and
they're willing to give everything they
possibly can to it
and you have enough of those guys who
kind of buy into that kind of culture
that's when you're able to do real real
special things and he loved the culture
of his football team
because of that because it was that way
and he said he himself was that way
and he figured that out you know during
the during the pandemic last year where
for the first couple weeks he said it
was cool that
you know he could play some golf and he
would be around his family and all that
he's
but you know over time it was like i
need this game
i need to be around the guys i need to
be coaching i need to be game planning
because that's who i am and that's what
i want to do and all those guys who you
talk about
and you're right all the greats who we
all love and we all revere
they had that maniacal
passion and love for the game to where
nothing stood in their way when it came
to trying to be one of the greats of all
time
and that all i was saying was that's
what's going to be expected of trevor
both because he's going number one
overall
and because all every step of the way
that's what's happened to him he's been
the best guy on the field
well now he's not going to necessarily
be the best guy on the field anymore
there's going to be a plenty of guys and
there's going to be plenty of teams that
go up against
that they're going to feel like wake
forest they're going to feel like boston
college against clemson and they're
going to feel like
okay we still have a little bit of a
ways to go to build out our program now
how are you going to respond to that
and how you gonna motivate everyone else
around that and you know what
i'm gonna bet on the fact that he's
going to anyway simply because the guy
is special
i believe the guy is special i'm just it
was just
surprising to hear someone be so honest
about something like that
in a day and age where you know this
game is hard man
it's just hard at the nfl level it's
very different and i know that firsthand
it's
different see i was more concerned that
he said it not that he thought it
that he said it yeah you know what i it
takes
you know well there there's there's
plenty of people who also at the same
time dan were like praising him for
saying it saying that it was
it reflected awareness and maturity and
comfort in his own standing maybe it
does
wait a minute if if zach wilson said
let's say sam darnold came out and said
that
well that's what that was we would crush
sam darnold
that was exactly my point we would apply
a different standard to those
individuals and say
hey wait a second oh red flag here red
flag
of course we would of course we would
uh great to talk to you and uh hopefully
we'll talk to you before
we get to the draft but uh thanks again
for joining us lewis of course
anytime man that's louis riddick espn
funding uh funday night
it's funday night it's monday night
football and a former nfl player
former pro scout director of pro
personnel